see this morning has partnered with the
professional networking sites LinkedIn
for our continuing series called work in
progress it explores the future of jobs
and the issues facing the American
workforce this morning we look at how
employers are handling the booming job
market hiring is up more than 17 percent
nationwide compared to July 2016
according to LinkedIn workforce report
for August but in some parts of the
country managers face challenges ranging
from an employee skills gap to the
growing problem of prescription drug
abuse
LinkedIn's editor-in-chief Dan Roth is
with us now good morning morning so tell
us what these reports tell us about the
capacity to go hire well you're seeing a
lot of industries who are seeing
double-digit growth and hiring and
they're especially in the kind of drill
and build areas Manufacturing oil and
gas is in double-digit growth aerospace
manufacturing places where you actually
need people to go and build things that
other people are gonna buy these are
areas that hadn't been growing in the
past this year since January we've seen
a lot of growth across the country in
almost every industry but especially in
these days so how do they use LinkedIn
to recruit people one of the we're
looking at here is that what workers are
telling us about where they live where
they're working what kind of jobs and
skills that they currently have so it's
not about recruiters necessarily it's
about people saying they're updating
their their jobs to say I'm not working
at this manufacturing company I'm
working at oil and gas and then we can
also see the skills gap in certain
cities what are which jobs are getting
picked up the fastest what are people
getting hired for and what aren't they
getting hired for and we're seeing
different skills gaps across the country
and what are the some of those skills
gap well especially in cities there are
certain cities where hiring is just
booming you look at Seattle Portland
Oregon Denver there are places where a
lot of tech absolutely and also
manufacturing and and some of the oil
and gas and schuster especially but
what's happening is that as these jobs
as professionals come in across the
country to fill these jobs there are
other jobs that that aren't getting
filled things like education retail
health care especially places when
workers come in and they need support
they want they send their kids to school
they need health care services and but
but people who would normally fill those
jobs are getting priced out of the
market
Danny also looked at the cities and the
places in this country that have been
hard hit by the opioid crisis and how
it's affecting job hiring what did you
find
yeah so you look at there's a skills gap
across the country employers can't hire
but they also can't hire because they
can't find people who can pass drug
tests this is amazing we keep hearing
employers telling us one of the top
problems they're facing is that people
are failing drug tests or they come in
and then they fail a drug test or they
start working and then they discover
that people are addicted to drugs and
they're addicted to drugs that they're
getting from their doctors they can't
just it's not like you just show up
drunk at work one day and you're fired
these are people who have a prescription
they're saying it's okay that I'm on
these drugs but they can't actually do
the jobs and it's getting to the point
where we talked to a manufacturer in
Ohio who said that he now no longer
makes people take drug tests he just
asked them to tell him what they're
wrong he says tell me are you taking
crack are you on heroin I will manage
around that it's not it's not worth it
to him to have to pay to have them take
drug tests that they're gonna fail or
that they're gonna pass and then fail
later so they're just accommodating this
addiction absolutely they are either
accommodating and trying to figure out
how to accommodate it they're hiring
people who have who have gone through
addiction centers and are now better
they're hiring immigrants they are
hiring people for the further or better
way to think about this what do you want
professionals medical professionals well
I think the medical professionals are
struggling with the opioid epidemic I'm
wondering how to treat pain while also
not giving people so many drugs that
they can't actually function in the u.s.
this is a massive problem what we're now
seeing is that it's actually affecting
employers too and it's affecting
competitiveness of American companies
because if they don't allow for this
addiction they're saying that there
would be a dearth of people that they
could hire yeah they can't fill these
jobs they can't I get people in the door
there what we we heard from people who
are not on drugs who are saying us a
boom time for me I'm getting jobs as a
driver I'm getting jobs as a
manufacturer I'm being rude all over the
place because I can pass a drug test
that's now a competitive asset to have
and they're no questions here of in this
recruitment about skills having the
necessary skills for these jobs you got
to have the skills you also have to be
able to pass a drug test
so it's this double whammy that
employers are facing the economy is
doing well people can get jobs that they
want to get they're moving to go fill
the jobs they realize there are skills
gaps across the country and people are
starting to now
either build the skills they need to
remove where they can fill them but
employers are saying it's costing them
more they can't find the right people
and they can't find people who can pass
these drug tests
thank you I said I give an Rock thank
you very much jobs numbers tomorrow
exactly